for if you're a republican you know this
this election is about
saving your country from the anarchic
chaotic radical left
if you are a democrat this election is
about saving the country from trumpism
and the
radical far right
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster
i'm constantly kissing and this is a
show for you
if you want honest conversations with
fascinating people
our brilliant and returning guest today
is a professor of politics at the
university of kent
and the author of national populism a
revolt against liberal democracy
matt goodwin welcome back to
trigonometry thanks for having me i did
that all from memory you must be
impressed
that's great it's really not impressive
second time it's your second time was
saying it
uh third time it's good to have you back
matt it's great to be here i watch every
episode
i sent some episodes to my mother as
well that's how impressive i think the
show is well that's very kind and
actually if someone of of your caliber
and stature watches our show i think
that's that's a positive
i would urge everybody to watch
trigonometry well they already are mates
uh so anyway it's good to have you back
uh
the last time we had you on it was one
of i think one of our best episodes that
we've ever done
uh it was in the wake uh of the election
uh in 2019 and december 20. no pressure
by the way i think it was two days after
this it was literally two days
i don't think i'd slept actually i think
it was just straight from
crunching the election to your studio
really yeah or how things haven't
changed
you haven't slept very much i haven't no
no but you're working hard and we'll get
into some of the work that you're doing
but at that time we were talking about
the collapse of the labour party
the the problems on the left now we've
got another
fairly important election coming up uh
in november in the united states and
that's why we're so delighted to have
you back because i think
uh they always say this is the most
important election in
uh well it kind of is isn't it
it's a highly consequential election for
lots of different reasons i think
on the one hand it's a referendum on
trump
the guy that of course we all thought
wouldn't win
but it's also going to tell us
ultimately whether liberalism
mainstream politics has a reply to
populism and that essentially is what
november is about
when you say sort of self-deprecatingly
something we all said wouldn't happen
you
actually tried to get people to
recognize that trump would be elected in
2016.
well i wrote a piece uh explaining why i
thought trump would win
um and i mean it's an interesting story
i suppose
i used to write um quite regularly for
the new york times and
uh mainly on stuff about europe and then
during the summer of 2016
uh thought that people were obsessing
about the national polls and they were
losing sight of the state level polls
and they were losing sight of the groups
that uh were more likely than
than others to turn out in my opinion
and fast forward to the election that's
kind of what happened anyway i sent that
piece to the new york times so i thought
trump would win
um it wasn't published because at that
point we were dealing with you know 99
implied chance of a trump victory sent
it to politico who did publish it
um and uh i think at that point it was
very much
about trying to learn from the
experiences of britain and learn about
what you know
what was the message of the referendum
that actually there are some fundamental
problems with the way that we poll
certain groups and there are some
issues with how we interpret people's
enthusiasm and elections and
and that played out obviously uh to
trump's benefit
um so i think you know 2016 was you know
the big shock
and and since then i know we're going to
talk about it but since then obviously
we've learned a great deal too
not only about trumpism but also about
how you respond to
somebody like trump and we're seeing
trump now he seems to be on the back
foot doesn't he in terms of the polls as
a result of covid
was it very much the case that if kovid
had never happened he would have
absolutely stormed the election would
have been a bit more complicated
i think trump would have won without
covid i think it would have been
fairly comfortable the reason i say that
firstly is if you look at the polling
uh on the economy he had a significant
lead even at the beginning of this year
uh he also we tend to forget this now
he also has a fairly clear record
and list of things that he can point to
for his supporters you know standing up
to china
building part of the wall tax breaks
judges all of that kind of stuff that
republicans want to see he you know he
has delivered
for some of his uh key groups of voters
um but i think also at the same time um
the democrats have focused
overwhelmingly on the
anti-trump message and haven't yet at
least in my view articulated the
pro-democrat message and i think that's
symbolic of a deeper problem within our
politics
particularly in the west which is that
liberalism
has not really renewed itself uh
in a in an instrumental positive way
it's very good at saying
why its opponents are evil racist
ignorant etc
it still has not renewed its core
message to voters i.e why is it relevant
today what does it want to achieve
what's its vision for society i mean if
you told me
or ask me today what's biden's vision
for the united states
apart from it not involving donald trump
i don't really know
maybe there's a bit of stuff around
clean energy bit of stuff about making
it easier to join unions
a bit of stuff about taxing higher high
earners
what's the vision right and i think that
speaks to a deeper problem
facing not only social democracy but
facing liberals in general
well we had scott adams on the show and
he in fact said that he's never met
a biden fan and if you've never met a
biden fan
there's plenty of trump fans how is he
possibly going to get elected
well he'll get elected uh if he if he if
he does get elected
through increased turnout among
uh the key groups uh university
graduates um african-americans
um suburban voters women um
and you know compared to clinton at this
point in 2016
biden is in a stronger position um he
is doing better in the polls uh
nationally
um he's doing better in some swing
states than clinton was doing but
i still think trump has has got a very
good chance at the election
uh if you drill down into some of those
states of florida for example
trump is competitive i think biden's
having some real problems with hispanic
latino
voters in some specific counties
and i think the job numbers do matter
you know
i don't agree with the narrative that
it's all culture and economics doesn't
have anything to say
i think as long as trump is able to say
there's another one and a half million
going back to work this month
the markets are beginning to stabilize
albeit having a bit of a wobble
uh uh recently um he's going to be able
to have that sort of let's not ruin it
narrative and of course then there's
law on order and there's this issue of
safety and basic security which i think
ultimately will will play uh to trump's
advantage
and the other thing perhaps it's deeper
than all of that um
is the sort of way in which liberalism
has become
detached from what it was supposed to be
and it's morphed into
this sort of hyper liberalism that is
quite um disparaging of
the national community and it seeks to
repudiate many of the symbols and the
myths and the identities that come with
that
national community whether that's
expressed in terms of
questioning the underlying foundations
of that country or tearing down
important symbols for particular
people in particular states or rewriting
the narratives of history most people
still primarily identify with their
country and most people derive
their sense of self-esteem from that
national identity so the more and more
we see that being pulled apart and
questioned and
the more more we're saying to citizens
you should feel bad for coming
you know for being born into this
country and coming from this country the
more and more you will stoke a backlash
against that and of course trump
benefited
from that partly in 2016 but if anything
the volume of that
i think has increased significantly
since then well i'm an immigrant so i'm
better than you
um you mentioned the polls quite a lot
there uh which i
i think is interesting to talk about
because i've been watching you
on twitter talking about the polls i
mean it's a big part of what you do
commenting on on the different
information that's coming in on the data
uh
tell us more about that in terms of how
people perceive
uh trump in the sense that you know the
economy was
so i mean you can argue about it but the
economy certainly was doing well
by the convention and ways of measuring
growth unemployment all of that stuff
was doing well
uh then covet hits has has the covert
been factored in in the sense of people
going
yeah i mean look no one was going to
maintain unemployment at the record
level low levels that it was uh with
covid or people going it's all trump's
fault
you know he's responsible uh the economy
is going to be screwed because of him
etc like what was
how is that broken for him so trump has
lost ground
in terms of how people perceive his
handling of
coronavirus he's become weaker on those
indicators
he's now level with biden on the economy
in a couple of polls he's been trailing
but the point is that when you ask that
question who do you think would better
manage the economy
um only around 35 36 of people are
picking trump or biden
so there's not an overwhelming
enthusiasm for either candidate
um the other thing that's changed which
might be significant is that
the large majority of americans now say
america is heading in the wrong
direction
uh and that they think that they and
their families are worse off
than they were four years ago and so i
think around the polls what you're
seeing is a general
mood of disillusionment and despondence
despondency among americans
now of course that can be interpreted in
different ways that's not to say it's
all
anti-trump i think there's just a sense
of despair
about what is happening to their country
and i think they look around at the
protests and the police officers being
shot and the
harassment and the polarization and just
clearly they can see their country well
and there's a pandemic too and the right
direction and the pandemic yeah it's
true
so so i think trump's position in many
ways has weakened but i would still
argue that the democrats and biden have
yet to cut through in terms of the
positive message now obama did that
obama cut through overwhelmingly
um but to me the biden campaign has
quite a few similarities with the remain
campaign in in the uk and many
similar campaigns in europe in that it's
overwhelmingly focused on the
the negative aspects of its opponents
rather than setting out that positive
uh vision of a sort of biden biden
america
uh and and that's where you can see on
the polling questions around how do you
feel about biden
a lot of voters are still not
enthusiastic
about biden including democrats he's not
inspiring the same kind of grassroots
mobilization that say obama was able to
do
and on many of the enthusiasm questions
trump still has
uh quite an advantage um you know in
that i think
unlike 2016 this election is probably
seen
uh as being uh more existential right
for if you're a republican
you know this this election is about
saving your country from the anarchic
chaotic radical left
if you are a democrat this election is
about saving the country from
trumpism and the radical far right
and so the stakes have gone up for both
sides and that means that whoever wins
uh the other side is going to feel uh as
though in some ways they're losing their
country
and that's why i think america is in
such a dangerous position
is an issue there's been a concern for i
think everybody and we'll get into what
happens if this happens what happens if
that happens
with with trump but the the thing that
you said there
seems to me quite interesting on the one
hand you say trump still has
a good chance on the other hand you say
that he's par with bide on the
on the economy now i i'm not
the the smartest person in the room but
what did you please repeat that
it's because matt is here i'm just
saying for him plus anton
but what i'm hearing there is the social
stuff
is where you are seeing people really
feeling like
trump is maybe protecting them from
something or
not on side with people who are coming
you said it's existential is that going
to be the driver here do you think
i think uh there are probably a lot of
voters who might not be expressing their
view
that might be expressing what we call a
social desirability bias that trump is
so toxic that perhaps they
feel that they can't really confess to
voting for him after the
um you know [ __ ] show of the last four
years but also i think at the same time
there's a lot that can change
between now and early november the job
numbers can change the economy can begin
to improve the cases could start to go
down
trump could point to weaknesses within
biden we have the debates to come we
have a lot of things that could
um that could uh play a significant role
and you know it's not a popular point
trump's a good campaigner
uh trump is good on on at the grassroots
now whether the covid
um virus and the the lack of rallies and
the difficulty with organizing that
on the ground you know will that hurt
trump possibly
uh you know not forecasting and saying
categorically trump is going to win the
election but
if anything i think over the last few
weeks we've seen things beginning to
move in trump's direction in some of the
polling
um and i wouldn't at all be surprised if
that carries on
uh biden has been very quiet um
and he's not really shown himself to be
the charismatic
uh unifier that we expected
final question from me on just that line
of questioning matt if you were advising
the biden campaign right now
what would you tell him to do the same
thing i'd tell kierstama to do which is
start to explain why you love the
country
what do you love about america stop
telling people what you want to tear
down and what you want to change about
the country
what do you love about the country and
why do you want to come from that
country what do you identify with
and this is the same problem that runs
through center-left politics today
in that it's become so detached
from uh ordinary average public opinion
so at times self-absorbed and neglectful
of how ordinary people think and feel
that it can no longer articulate why it
is
it wants to be in that country it's
constantly talking about what's wrong
with that country it's constantly
repudiating
institutions traditions myths symbols
and voters have picked up on that
and as a researcher there's not an easy
way that we can survey that and i can
say to you
categorically this is what makes a
difference but if you look at the
comprehensive defeat
of jeremy corbyn uh you know less than a
year ago
and if you look at trump's win in 2016
and you look at the rise of
populism and you look at the collapse of
social democracy across much of europe
for me at least and i'm happy for people
to disagree with me i think what runs
through all of those moments
is a clear sense among voters that they
are sick of politicians telling them
what is
wrong with their country and they are
proud to be from that country
and they like being from that country
and they derive their sense of esteem
and identity from that country and
that's
quite different from over ethnic
nationalism
and so i think the left and um in some
ways moderate
centrist liberals too sometimes miss a
trick on that um and you know it's the
old debate that we've had on the show
many a time but
i would tell biden go out there and tell
people what you love about america
in the same way that i say to kirsten i
go out there and say to people why do
you love britain
do you enjoy watching problematic
content online that you don't want your
friends or family to know about
of course they do they watch
trigonometry mate well we have just the
solution for you
it's called expressvpn at the moment
your isp is able to track
every single website that you go to and
then they sell that information onto
advertisers and others
expressvpn allows you to prevent that
from happening
it also means that you can be located in
a different region to the one that your
ip shows up as
we always use expressvpn for our
browsing thumbnail francis
absolutely and by the way you sound like
an expert
keep your browsing history to yourself
visit expressvpn.com
forward slash trigger today to get three
months free subscription
visit expressvpn.com
trigger that's e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
trigger today good job spelling out for
the med it doesn't sound patronizing at
all
absolutely and by the way all those
little words you use i've got no idea
what they mean
it seems that we've talked a lot about
biden we haven't really addressed the
elephant in the room which is
he doesn't appear to be in the best
possible shape
we've summoned sometimes when he's
speaking he's stumbling over words
his campaign seems to be unclear do you
think that will have an
impact in that people see him and think
to themselves he's not physically well
enough to be present
because there is a narrative being
perpetuated about him
i think it would matter more if he was
facing someone who was clearly
mentally balanced and competent
and i think because he's facing trump in
a way that's sort of neutralized
yeah um but we also know through things
that we've experienced in this country
take jeremy corbyn as an example i think
there was a there was an awareness among
lots of voters in 2017
the corbyn was not in the prime you know
time of his life he was not
the most energetic and sort of
passionate etc
um and yet he still did he still did
fairly well um
so but nobody thought he had dementia
matt nobody thought he had to measure
sure but i
i i don't i'm not convinced that is as
big a factor as it may be now of course
we might get to the debates and you guys
might
sort of sit here and perhaps see one of
your live shows
during the debates and your body might
fall apart we don't know
um but but i think he can probably hold
it together in fact if anything
our expectations of biden now might be
so low
that he may end up leaving us pleasantly
surprised
really and how big an influence do you
think those debates are going to be
because at the moment it seems as if
well as as
you said trump is behind but trump seems
to thrive in that particular environment
yeah i think i think political
scientists might argue that debates and
the effects of debates are overblown in
the media
but there's something about this year
where i think we can all sort of sense
that the stakes are high and maybe this
year
this is going to matter more than usual
you know we've seen so little abide in
during the campaign um we know that
trump
if he's up against the wall we know that
he's going to come out swinging
that's you know what trump does we know
that's what he did with clinton
we know he was aggressive and combative
and we know that all of the optics that
went into those debates
you know the women that were associated
with bill clinton etc all of that stuff
was designed to kind of undermine and
psychologically um unnerve his opponent
so i think there'll be lots more tricks
in the bag that are going to come out
from the trump campaign as we go into
those debates and we can already i think
guess what those are going to be with
regards to
to biden um but but but again it comes
down to will biden himself be able to
not get sucked into that keep distance
and and
present to america what his unifying
positive instrumental message really is
and of course the one thing i would say
is unlike obama
what did obama do quite well he said
it's not the red states of america not
the blue states the united states of
america i think we be
we've got we've come so far down the
kind of hyper liberal road
now we've come so far down the identity
politics road now
it's impossible for biden to say that
now that we are
very quickly um defining politics by
group identities and by racialized group
identities
and it's almost as if that brief moment
for the democrats that brief window of
opportunity to unify people
around something that brings them
together rather than things that
separate them like their racial identity
we've kind of gone by gone past that now
so um
i've been rereading a guy michael lind
uh the american writer who i recommend
to everybody
michael lin's book the next american
nation in 1995 is one of
one of the most influential books i
think at least for me is very
uh insightful on the us politics and
michael's argument in that is
in essence you've gone through two
stages in in the post-war period you've
had the foot in terms of civil rights
you've had the first stage
where essentially civil rights
campaigners were focused on
colorblind advancement bringing
different groups together
to make america a more equal fair
tolerant country
and then really from the 70s onwards you
have a second approach that kicks in
that is
principally about asymmetric
multiculturalism
affirmative action you know race-based
policy
and that is implicitly encouraging
people to think about themselves
not as americans per se but
as uh belonging to particular groups and
the moment that you then start to move
down that spiral
uh move down that road so you can't
really get people to focus any more
on what's cutting across those group
boundaries so it becomes harder and
harder to mobilize that broad
church at big ten politics and i think
that's roughly where we are now and of
course
i know you've had other people on the
show that make this point too but if you
look for example some of the work in the
us
we now know that that is really
increasing the likelihood that
white americans are now thinking of
themselves as
white americans rather than americans
and that all of this
is simply increasing the salience of
people's race
racial and ethnic identity and this is a
worrying place i think to be
in an advanced society where people are
being encouraged to think of themselves
in that way and so biden i don't think
we'll be able to get back to that
cross-group message
there's a question that i wanted to ask
because it's somebody there's a figure
on the democrats
side who had an appeal and in my opinion
had a cut through maybe i'm wrong
and could appeal to the donald trump
supporter which is bernie sanders
do you think if we had that type of
figure of bernie sanders s figure
he would be a more unifying influence as
you were talking mate i had my money you
were going to say tulsi gabbard
i would i would have quite liked to have
seen bernie sanders versus trump in
2016.
yeah i don't think it would have been
necessarily the recipe for healthy
moderate
balanced politics but just as a just as
an experiment
yeah to see who really would have won
you know that contest
uh i think my view would be
that trump would win that and i think
the simple reason
is that again for radical
uh socialists for center-left social
democrats the problem they all
face actually is they're being out
they're being attacked on two flanks
whereas they are only speaking on one
flank so you've got economic security
and cultural security
and cultural security has become more
important in recent years for all of the
reasons that we know
immigration terrorism transnational
organizations
rapid social and ethnic change
but center-left politicians radical life
socialists are kind of
stuck in this mindset
that this is all about economic scarcity
and economic competition
and so all of this stuff is just racism
so we're not really going to engage with
it and we're going to shut it down and
we're just going to say this is really
just about resources and how we
distribute resources
and as a consequence they've been
outflanked from one country to another
constantly
because at the same time many of the
populace from trump to
farage to le pen also changed and that
they were saying well
we've always talked about the cultural
stuff but now let's get a bit more
protectionist on the economy
too let's start saying well hang on why
are all of these big multinationals
dodging their taxes or
for trump let's turn up the volume on
anti-china and
reshoring and bringing back businesses
to the u.s so
you know both of those moves i think
really left populous in a much more
competitive position because then
they're attacking the left
on the economic dimension but they're
also constantly berating the left
on the cultural dimension too and that
is where
we still are in essence and that's that
is still the riddle
that kierstama and biden and every other
center-left social democrat
needs to answer and you can say well
let's take the danish road and maybe
we'll turn up the volume on
immigration control and try and kind of
meet these parties halfway or you could
go
the complete opposite direction and say
no that that constituency is done
we're going to remain firmly socially
liberal and we're going to
uh remain uh economically
interventionist and we're going to
appeal to this new coalition of
university graduates and minorities
which is probably where many within the
labor party i think still are
um but one way or the other if they
don't solve that riddle
they're not going to get back into power
you talk about solving the riddle for
the center-left parties
i mean one of the things that i think
whether you're a trump fan
and we have some trump fans who watch
the show or biden's
not biden fan as well that's not many of
those but certainly a democratic
supporter
we have many of them vote uh watching
the show as well
the one thing they can all agree on is
that the two candidates that the main
parties
have ended up with let's just say a
sub-optimal
to put it very mildly right how do the
democrats in particular because
you know trump won so you can see why
people would be with him from from then
he is the president
he's as you say delivered on some of the
things that he promised but how do the
democrats
who who are targeting that progressive
coalition that you talk about
end up with a very old very white man
leading that
uh why haven't they got someone better
i think there is a supply side problem
well i i think they had they
experimented with
you know various candidates during the
the primaries it didn't work out and i
think
what they've gone back to is the safe
territory it's the
um it's obama revivalism right biden is
very different from obama in many ways
he's more radical economically than
obama was
but they've gone back to what they think
they
know right which is let's go back to the
regime
that won before we had trump and this is
what i
mean about the retrospective liberalism
that
you see it all over the place you see it
in the kind of complaining of
mainstream newspaper columnist can't we
just go back to the days of blair in the
third way
and you see it in the positioning of
political parties
from labor to the democrats is this
still this reluctance to accept
that the rules of the game have changed
and the foundations of politics
have changed and the constituencies and
the electorates that used to support
those types of projects have changed
they've moved
and the dam has broken and if you just
take the uk as an example
the reason the red wall collapsed
similar to the
the reason the rust belt states went to
trump is because we now have millions of
voters who are cross-pressured
who are leaning left on the economy but
leaning
right on culture and i've just finished
a study for the joseph ranchery
foundation
and we talked about this when we last
met after the election we've just gone
back and run the numbers and what you
see in the uk for example is that all of
the people
that labour should have held on to in
many of those red wall seas
the one thing they noticed was labor
shifting to the
pro second referendum position so they
noticed that
they saw that and that was the cue for
them to say okay this party's not
interested
in where i am on this cultural question
anymore i'm off
and i think in the same way biden needs
to be very careful because the cues that
he's sending to some of the voters you
know michigan
wisconsin pennsylvania and so on they
have to be positive ones
they have to be okay right i'm going to
bring back the jobs i'm going to bring
back manufacturing i'm going to be tough
on china
i mean biden is almost as tough on china
as trump is if you look at his policy
platform i'm going to you know focus on
not just your economic interest but
accept that actually
the pace of change in america is too
great and we need to perhaps
as we did in the early 20th century slow
down for a decade or so
and then think about you know getting
back to that change in the future
um but until until they can do that
you know they're not going to get back
in the game how can he possibly do that
if he was to start sort of articulating
that cultural position
he would be strung up by his balls by
the far left of his own
i think i think there are different ways
of doing it right so take
take um what do we mean by this cultural
dimension right we mean voters that hold
socially conservative values who
prioritize order
stability tradition family
they're anxious about crime
they value conformity they don't like
what they see as relentless churn and
change those social conservative voters
and we see them in questions like
do you think we should bring back
capital punishment do you think that we
should teach
children greater discipline do you think
that
social change is moving too quickly all
of those kinds of things right
there are different ways of tapping into
that so for example what did blair do
quite well i mean i
appreciate blair as a somewhat
controversial figure on the left
the one thing blair did very well is he
said let's get tough
on crime but tough on the causes of
crime and that was before we have the
era of large-scale migration so of
course he could get away with a bit more
than perhaps he could today uh where
those issues have become more important
but that was tapping into the cultural
dimension in
in the same way that say a labor leader
or a democrat today
saying i think we should have a pause
on large-scale migration for five years
so that we can help
american workers or british workers or
whatever
um and that's what i mean by tapping
into that dimension and you can do it in
other ways you can be national pride
in expressing belief in the country and
um even when jeremy corbyn and john
mcdonnell were talking about their
strategy around um
build it in britain you know some of
those campaign messages i think
might have actually tapped into some of
the concerns in redwood seats because
voters might have interpreted that as
being
actually they are quite interested in in
in sort of respecting the country and
that still i think is why corbyn did
reasonably well in 2017 because he came
up with that position that said on the
one hand i
respect where you are on brexit and
we're gonna we're gonna do it but on the
other hand i
accept that you feel this system is
rigged uh and it's
in a way corbyn should have held on to
that position and not being pushed off
it
have you ever been abroad and felt out
of place because you didn't speak the
language
no because i voted brexit mate brexit
means brexit
uh i know that when you go on holiday
sometimes you don't speak the language
it can feel really awkward
a little bit like francis talking to a
woman do you want to learn another
language
no i don't for obvious reasons but if
you do
then babel is quite simply one of the
finest apps to use to achieve your goal
it is it's got amazing simple to use
interface they've got daily 10 to 15
minute lessons that you can do
that have been proven effective in many
studies as a great way to learn one of
14
languages that they offer so it doesn't
matter if you've got struggle with
language
for a variety of different reasons maybe
you find it tough or maybe you're just
english
right now babel is offering trigonometry
fans
six months completely free all you got
to do is head over there get the six
month subscription
and use our special code which is of
course trigger
go to babble dot co dot uk
play and use the promo code trigger on
your six month subscription
that's b a b b e l dot co
dot uk forward slash play and use the
code
trigger and we're not going to explain
how to spell the word trigger
because that would be patronizing
[Music]
absolutely now we've touched it already
in this interview but something that i
really wanted to explore with you and i
think a lot of people are very worried
about this
i don't think any one of those two
parties are gonna
accept the fact that they lost in good
grace
and doesn't that leave democracy in a
very dangerous position
so i i would say the one thing i think
we all want to see
is a clear outcome yeah the nightmare is
the sort of 2000
rerun where you have an election that
just is not resolved
for you know 30 odd days and everybody's
standing in limbo while we count the
postal votes and
some of the states are contested or
somebody wins a popular vote by a mile
but another candidate wins the electoral
college
um just for the sake of electoral
integrity
and as you know a friend of america and
you know i think we
here i think would want to see a kind of
clear outcome but there is an
interesting question i think much of the
debate now is focused on
what is going to happen if trump loses i
think the
equally interesting question is what is
going to happen if biden loses
because both sides are so invested in
this election outcome
you know the idea that just one side is
delegitimizing this election is nonsense
i mean it's going on on both sides
both sides campaigners commentators
politicians
are in a race to the bottom already to
try and delegitimize this election so we
might as well just
call it what it is but for democrats who
i think have been
you know obviously become more convinced
in their belief
around the scale of discrimination in
american society
the threat of trump-ism the
belief that the foundations and the
institutions of american democracy
are now at risk um
you know what is going to happen to that
sentiment if trump wins again
because it's it's i think it would be
such a devastating blow
because it will remind everybody firstly
that
they don't have the answers um secondly
that liberalism doesn't have the answer
to populism
they need to go back to the drawing
board and start all over again
everything that's happened over the last
four years
has not made a difference and in my mind
i go back to um
you know the five stages of grief the
five stages of loss
it came out in 1969 where
the um elizabeth cooper ross talked
about
you start with denial which i think
we've gone through over the last
four years you go to anger
we've seen that i think we've seen which
is the sort of dismissal and the
derision that's thrown at anybody who
holds a view that is not
consistent with the liberal consensus
and then you get to bargaining
and you have to bargain with the other
side and you have to try and
reach this new settlement you have to
try and give them something
to try and bargain it out before you can
think about getting close to the end
state of acceptance
and i i don't think we've come out of
denial
or anger yet i think we're still in that
phase and i
if you look at the books that are coming
out you know the end of democracy you
know the
uh the collapse of american society
the ops the sort of continual turning in
of commentary it's become much more
insular in america over the last four
years in an already insular country
it's become obsessed with deconstructing
uh the foundations of the country and i
think all of that points to this
denial and anger and inability to
articulate a response and if trump wins
again
it's difficult to see how all of that
doesn't
you know doesn't just go onto steroids
you know you just have this
you know outpouring of disbelief and
frustration and anger and despair
um i think it's safe to say that trump
probably wouldn't manage that with
dignity
[Laughter]
he made this point when we had him on
the show yeah he did indeed there's one
final question that i want to ask you on
that
do you think what we're starting to see
is the breakup of the union
just this incredible polarization
between red and blue
you have states which are blue which
will always be blue states so it'll
always be red and the fact that we just
can't
seem to talk to each other anymore i
don't
i don't know it's a short answer i think
the problem that america has
post cold war uh maybe china will fill
the void is that it doesn't have
the um existential
external threat that combined
americans together so what we've seen
since the end of the cold war
are i i think at least americans turning
in on themselves
because they don't have the grand
narratives that perhaps they once had
to try and provide that unity and
coherence
so as a consequence you know i think
they've become
much more insular much more engaged
in themselves uh rather than perhaps
trying to
to promote unity against you know russia
or you know whoever else and that's a
real problem for them i'm not going to
say who it is but i
had this i had a similar conversation
with a very prominent u.s academic
not long ago um and asked him the same
question but
do you think living in america observing
everything you're observing do you think
that america will hold
hold itself together and he said i'm not
sure uh
i'm not sure where we'll be you know 30
40 years from now and of course there
have been prophecies that
the united states will will will fall
apart samuel huntington for example was
one who not so long ago argued that in
an era of rapid
change that uh southern states um would
essentially
uh uh leave the union not because they
would
voluntarily opt out but because
essentially they would be
taken over and in in so far we've
discovered that huntington was not not
correct in that prediction
um but one of his main concerns at the
same time
was that america would fall into the
hands of what he called a denationalized
elite
uh that didn't identify with the country
and that was more interested in
deconstructing
american history and he worried as well
that that would have
pretty disastrous effects on the
cohesion of american society
i think what's interesting too is if you
look at writers on the
left and the right think about some of
the most influential books over the last
let's say 20 years robert putnam bowling
alone
charles murray coming apart um
[Music]
huntington's who are we um
those books john coddling of the
american mind
all of those books in a way have been
sort of saying the same thing which is
internally the social fabric is being
stretched over time uh angus eaton death
of despair is another
and that if you are white middle-aged
working class
life generally is getting worse for you
and if you're from
you know the coast university educated
middle class elite
you're gradually drifting away not just
economically but socially and culturally
so we know these things are happening
but nobody has yet got a good answer to
that
i think what we're seeing in the uk
we're on the same road but we're a few
miles behind
we can see many of the same things
actually happening in the uk not as
pronounced
we don't we don't have the opioid crisis
we don't have the healthcare system
but we do have growing levels of
disconnect between
these different groups socially and
culturally
so uh we should watch america and watch
what happens in america extremely
closely
well we wish them well because it
doesn't sound like a healthy recipe
which is one of the reasons we spent so
much time talking about it on the show
for so long because uh what happens in
america doesn't stay in america
as we know and it is troubling and you
know
francis previous and very good question
about the the repercussions of the
different outcomes when we had james
lindsey on the show
right this is one of the things that he
talked about i think it was the time we
had him on with peter pagusian
that a re-election of donald trump will
not
wake anybody who opposes him up to the
fact that they are maybe heading down
the wrong path
you will be seen as vindication of their
position which is
yes america is a white nationalist
country here's more evidence of that we
need to push harder we need to fight
more
against these evil people on the far
right
so you addressed what happens if trump
wins
what happens if trump loses
yeah i mean i think
i think there's a legitimate reason to
feel concerned about
the conclusion those voters will reach
if they feel as though
um you know their voices now
is now out of the political system and i
i think what worries me about america is
is that existential
sense of loss that the election is no
longer framed
about transactional policy i mean if you
go back and you even if you look at the
trump ads that have gone out over the
last two weeks
the trump ads are not about you know
let's increase taxes
on let's change policy xyz they're about
save your country i think in a way what
we're getting back to michael oakshott
talked about this a little bit the
political theory is that um on the one
hand you know
you have the politics of pragmatism
which is about technocracy
which is about the dry managerialism
of running a state and keeping a country
ticking over
and on the other hand you have the
politics of salvation
and national renewal and redemption
and in all democracies politics is the
sort of balance between those two so if
you think for example about remain and
leave in britain
remain was overly technocratic dry
managerial
and it lost voters and leave was
redemptive it was about saving your
country taking back control
and they existed in this awkward balance
and then you know
when the populists go a little bit too
far the technocrats come back in the
room and say well hang on a second you
want to rip up an international treaty
well let's have a conversation about
that i don't think you know
and i think in the same way with america
what you can see
clearly in this election is this sort of
sense of
on both sides their candidates being
ultimately about national salvation
so it's not about transactional policy
anymore it's a sense that if biden
doesn't win
i've lost my country to these right-wing
reactionaries
whereas if trump doesn't win you know
particularly for the more militant
white nationalists the militia groups
and those kinds of
people who gen you know clearly feel
that
something is fundamentally wrong with
their country for whatever reason
of course i think they're going to
conclude that their country has been
taken away from them etc and i think
that's where we're we're in a very
dangerous
place this idea of cumulative extremism
which you can see in some of the
coverage around portland that
one side is fending off against another
the moderate center is given way
and you've got this sort of low-level
tit-for-tat violence
that just sort of becomes normalized
over time you know the number of
occasions over the last couple of months
i've gone on and said you know
somebody's been shot in america
somebody's been killed
so just sort of feel like this is kind
of just normal
you know but this sort of legitimation
of tit-for-tat violence and how it just
gradually seems to
increase and i think that's where i get
concerned about america because
i used to live in america i used to live
in michigan um and uh it didn't feel
like that when i was there
felt um it felt a little bit more
cohesive and
there has been lots of people mainly on
the left mainly on my facebook feed who
have said been saying things that
there is a danger that trump won't see
the presidency
if he is that's nonsense i mean who
knows what trump will do i don't know
that's that's thanks no
i think i would be amazed if he did that
i think he probably we
we know what he'll do look at it like a
money-making opportunity to rebuild
brand trump and go and do whatever he
wants to do in the business world and
critique his successor
from the sidelines i think the
interesting question about trump losing
is what happens to the republicans
because the republicans then have
essentially two choices which is double
down on trumpism
which i don't think they'll do i think
they'll conclude like they did after
bush that
they need a revamp they need to move
back to the center
um and then you've got this interesting
choice between sort of
doing that through a kind of you know
neo-liberal
sort of center-right you know let's go
back to the liberal consensus business
friendly
you know let's stop talking about
migration let's just be you know good
old-fashioned conservatives
versus the sort of rubio stuff that we
can see coming through
let's actually be a bit more like tucker
carlson let's be a bit more
interventionist on the economy
and let's also keep the culture peddled
down
and i think those are the strategic
choices that the
republicans will face and something that
has clearly come through over the last
few years is just how influential some
of those voices really are
so if you look at what trump did with
the uh executive order on critical race
theory
i mean if you go back and you watch
tycho carlson i think the week before
had the
uh show and the guest saying this you
know this is what trump should do with
his executive order
he should remove all training involving
critical race theory from federal
agencies and institutions and the next
week trump did it word for word
uh so clearly this sort of orbit of
tucker carlson and those people it's
clearly
more influential than they than they
used to be so the republicans
will have this sort of strategic dilemma
um
facing them after after a trump loss
well as someone who's been on tucker
carlson
uh right and i have some very good ideas
about what
donald trump should do about youtube
donald if you're watching
or tucker rather if you're watching get
me on i've got some great ideas that
donald
the donald needs to hear um but we joke
about it and
you you talk about the situation
american the sort of clinical detached
way as is your job you know a professor
of politics but
for me as someone who's observing it i
find it very worrying
i find it incredibly worrying this
fraying of
what you're really describing if i can
paraphrase it is
a country that had a uniting myth
or uniting idea no harare would call it
a uniting myth of some kind
is now retreating into racial groups
and no longer speaking to
its common purpose it's common sense
of who these people are i mean that's an
incredibly dangerous recipe isn't it
yeah but i try and i try not to be
apocalyptic because i think you know if
you go
through history you know there's always
been apocalypticism there's always been
a sense of sort of doom and gloom and
despair
and america is also the country that has
been routinely written off over the
years but has managed to
hold itself together and keep going and
the american dream we tend to forget
this but it is highly individualistic
i mean it is ultimately about making
yourself successful
and rich and prosperous and and that
that is slightly different from
the cultures that we are more used to i
think in parts of europe so i'm
i'm probably less won over by the idea
that america is suddenly going to fall
apart i think
you know what is significant perhaps
over the longer term is that
in some sense the the communal bonds
that are there
in some senses are being undermined on
different levels
and i think that's what's becoming
problematic you've got the educational
divide where we can see people
pulling away from one another you've got
this sort of distant
insular political elite that that is
moving away from voters um you know
both in terms of their backgrounds being
very affluent often being
multi-millionaires but also their social
liberalism in many senses their cultural
liberalism um
and then i think we've got this lack of
external
challenge and threat that that is not
allowing i think americans to
define themselves against that in a in a
in a way that they would for example
against
you know against russia and against
communism
um and if anything they're looking
internally at the threats rather than
externally
um but we have to get away from this
politics of deconstruction because that
that is dangerous
i think where the more and more people
believe that you are
deconstructing their imagined community
and those unifying myths that you
pointed to
then what do they have to to cling on to
because there isn't really much else for
lots of people
and i think that's where we need to try
and accept the good and the bad and
watching nigel bigger on your show i
think made this point very eloquently
that um
history is complex and there are good
bits and there are bad bits and we need
to accept
both of those but the puritanical
approach to
national history that we can see even
today with the renaming of the uh
building in edinburgh um but also that
we've seen in the united states with the
various projects that have been pushed
by various media
i think it's incredibly unsettling for
most voters
who view their way of life and their
traditions and identities as being
not only eroded but as not being valued
and respected by those who are
in power um that's just not a good place
to be for anybody
and you you did your book you wrote your
book which is brilliant and it's
obviously all about populism
do you think we've reaching the end of
populism or do you still think it's got
a way to go
well our argument certainly is that
populism is entwined in democracy so you
can never really get rid of it it's sort
of always there
um and in a way you wouldn't want to get
rid of it because populism is um
in some ways there's a silver lining
it's always reminding us that there are
groups that are not represented in the
system and you know
it's not the same as fascism it's very
different it's
it's quite organic and it comes
according to the guardian
it comes from within i love the way he
always responds to our banter he just
ignores
of democracy so we're not going to get
rid of it and so populism has had a bad
crisis
you look at all the polling across
europe and north america salvini afd in
germany
um bolsonaro and brazil they've had bad
uh a bad coronavirus crisis their their
polar ratings have gone down
but we can also see during this crisis
that many of the social and economic
divides
that have been underpinning our society
for the last 30 years are being
exacerbated
most of the people who lost their job
early on were low income low educated
workers most of the people who suffered
their health effects
of coronavirus are those same groups
meanwhile we know the middle class
university graduates winners have been
at home
on zoom drinking corantinis and
generally things have been you know okay
and what was interesting at the
beginning of the crisis at least for me
is that our isolation at the beginning
was compulsory but over time it's become
voluntary
and some groups have been able to do it
because it's been an economic luxury
and other groups haven't been able to do
it and so we've seen
again this divergence between different
groups you've also seen it at the state
level
if you look at the eurozone the economic
divergence between north and south
has been exacerbated during this crisis
and the recovery story
in europe will be one of different speed
recoveries that will exacerbate the
story of divergence between north and
south
it's not to say the eurozone is going to
disintegrate but it is to say
that as we come out of this the divides
that
that really dominated the 2010s and led
to you know what was one of the most
volatile decades in a long time
uh those divides are going to still be
with us and probably be a little bit
bigger than they were
in earlier years so what was the message
of the 2010 great recession
we i mean if we had this conversation
as lehman brothers was collapsing and we
said let's predict what's going to
happen
as a consequence of this over the next
10 years would we have predicted
trump brexit bolsonaro salvini afd
you know le pen in the final round etc
etc we wouldn't have predicted it and i
think the
political effects of crises come
downstream we know this crisis is going
to have political effects
we know this is going to lead to
increased
volatility we know that voters are going
to be disillusioned
and pissed off we just don't know how
that is going to fire its expression
will it bring back the center left
because now voters are going to
want to talk about economic
redistribution unemployment
inequality tax or will it bring back the
populace
because voters are going to say i've had
enough of this you know
this is just an unsustainable settlement
we don't know
all i think we can say for certain and
you can replay this in 2029 and we can
all laugh at how wrong i was but
i think the 2020s are going to be just
as volatile
if not more volatile than the 2010s
well that's a nice positive oh great
thanks mate um
at least he didn't promise to eat his
hat yeah yeah that could have
that could have been difficult um it's a
it's an interesting time isn't it matt
it's a very interesting time what do you
if you had a gun to your head who's
gonna win
in november as of today i think biden
will win
really really that's interesting why but
as i said earlier i think a lot can
change yeah of course it can so we're
just for
for clarity we're recording this sort of
early mid-september
uh for people who are watching later why
at this point would you say that biden
will win
i think that uh i think that the
sheer hatred of trump
among various groups is going to boost
turnout and uh
conceal many of the weaknesses that
still face the democrats the lack of a
positive unifying message the um
all of the things that we've talked
about biden's personality issues and so
i think for
millions of americans trump is so
ghastly and it's such in their eyes an
aberration
that i think we will see turnout around
the block and i think that will be
millennials zoomers african-americans
it will be liberal graduates uh and i
think we'll be
surprised at the the backlash to trump
that's really interesting because i i
think it's going to be the other way
i still think a lot can change i just
think where we are now yeah
i think and we see we see it every day
on social media i think for americans
i think the trump project has just been
so
uh existential you know that uh when we
get closer to november they will all
individually be mulling over
you know that question of what can i do
to get america
into a different place uh and you know
turn out maybe maybe high on both sides
um but i think as of now and also given
where biden is just in terms of
statistics and polling i mean he's got a
stronger lead
than clinton had uh he's got a more
sustainable lead
um in some of the swing states you know
in some ways he's got an easier path
to to the to win the electoral college
um
than clinton did uh and he's got big
guns he can
he can bring out he's got some big guns
in terms of
people who who can help him uh
along the campaign like obama you mean
like obama yeah
anyone else um
well there's two obamas good point yeah
yeah
i think there's still incredible
question which one of them is bigger by
the way i think they're incredibly
powerful
uh i think obama is still for
a generation of um americans i think
you know as we get into the finals
straight
they are going to be bombarded by
those big guns and do you think as well
the reason obama's so powerful is that
when he walks on stage he's a
statesman-like figure even if you
disagree
with his politics the way he holds the
stage the way he conducts himself
the way he speaks he comes across like a
president
and when you combine it with someone
like trump and the way he's so divisive
on twitter and inflammatory that that is
really going to be the thing that pushes
biden over the line
i think obama appeals to the better
angels of
people's nature i think he is more
focused on the unifying aspects of
american culture and identity and i'm
not to say that's
not saying i'm necessarily a pro or
auntie i just think as a
strategist and a politician he's better
at getting people to turn out
than than biden is and i think probably
he
he's a lot better at doing that than
trump is
and if you go back and you watch the
2016 campaign obama really did keep his
distance
from uh hillary uh he wasn't
as prominent as perhaps we might have
expected him to be
and this time i think he's taken it very
personally and you can see that in how
the campaign has been uh evolving
around biden and i think for a lot of
people even today
you know i read that uh bloomberg is
giving biden 100 million for florida
i think a lot of the old guard elites
have taken trump very very
personally now i completely accept
there's an argument as we saw in britain
that if you line up the elite voters
will
rebel uh even more but i think even
among
ordinary americans i think there's
something about the trump project
that will increase their turnout
in a way that may be problematic for
trump
um but let's agree to well we'll see
what the hell do i know you're much more
of an expert on this you should come on
more often he's actually positively
humble today
no i know the presence of greatness
which for me working with you is a
rarity can i just say what do you think
is going to happen for us
he thinks the same thing is listen i
predicted trump i predicted brexit the
only thing i didn't predict was
leicester city i went for spurs in the
premier league so who's going to win in
november
trump sorry two trumps in a yeah i tell
you what though
if you if you do think whoever you think
there's a lot of value in the betting
markets right now yeah absolutely for
sure
we do not endorse gambling or whatever
gary the lawyer
in any show so we've just got time for
our final question i wanted to ask if
you thought
trump's been a good person but anyway we
won't do that yeah yeah that wouldn't
divide
him in a difficult position in any way
in any type of life okay cool
so what we the one thing we always end
with which is what is the one thing
we're not talking about
as a society that we really should be um
great question i think we have gone
through two stages
post 2016 right big 2016 results i think
the first stage was
get this stuff out of here um you know
democracy is over
these guys are fascists i think where we
are now the second stage
is much more interesting we're beginning
finally to talk about
the very understandable reasons why
people
felt uh they'd lost out from the
settlement and that's reflected in a
an array of new books that have come out
that have been questioning things like
where our
meritocracy has gone wrong that have
been questioning whether we got it right
with the liberal consensus that have
been questioning how liberalism has gone
come unstuck and become quite um
destructive and quite narcissistic i've
been going back and reading a lot of
interesting books in the 90s christopher
lash and others
looking at um at what they tell us about
today and i think
we we want to stay there it would be my
answer francis we want to stay
we want to keep the conversation focused
on
what led us to to come unstuck in the
first place because one of my fears
is biden wins in november
um bolsonaro loses
in brazil um kia stammer and the snp
win via coalition in 2024
25 and we sort of say
liberalism's back social democracy's
back we don't have anything to worry
about let's carry on
because i think that would be incredibly
misleading i think where we are now
where we're getting to
is a much more interesting national
conversation
finally about what brought us here in
the first place
and how can we make people's lives
better and whether that's through the
leveling up
agenda in the uk or whether it's about
coming up with interesting counter
policies
to trump to help some of the rust belt
states or whatever it is that's the more
interesting place to be
rather than this kind of polarized um
shouting match between both sides so
let's try and keep stay there i suppose
would be my plea
doesn't answer your question it does
indeed and thank you so much for coming
on matt uh if people want to find you on
twitter social media where's the best
place for it my twitter feed
yeah which is at goodwin mj at goodwin
mg perfect and make sure you get
national populism a revolt against
liberal democracy it's a great book
we've talked with matt several times as
you'll know
uh thank you for watching and we will
see you very soon with another brilliant
episode or live stream
and they all go out 7pm uk time tuesday
right the way through to sunday see you
soon guys
thanks for watching guys as always
subscribe to the youtube channel
click the bell button next to subscribe
button so you get notified when a video
comes out
and follow us on all the social media at
trigger pod
and also leave us a nice review on
itunes and spread the word